pour en parler nous sommes avec rené
georges querry ancien patron de l'unité
de coordination de la lutte
antiterroriste lui clac rené georges
querry merci d'être en direct avec nous
sur rt france alors peut-être un mot ce
procès qu'est-ce qu'il vous inspirent
ces témoignages glaçant le ça rappelle
évidemment ces événements absolument
terribles qui ont marqué le pays
mais ça rappelle aussi ça nous doit nous
mettre en alerte car le risque est
permanent et permanent ça veut dire que
des frères kwasi qui était au coeur des
échanges aujourd'hui on l'a dit il y en
a encore aujourd'hui dans la nature en
france et peut à tout moment avoir des
actions de ce type
il ne faut pas oublier que sur ces six
derniers mois il a eu quatre actions
individuelles en france qui ont entraîné
le des morts avec des armes à feu mais
avec des armes blanches et rien
n'empêche de penser qu'un tout moment
des individus peuvent avec des armes
automatiques sortir du bois si je vous
mets primaire ainsi et pour procéder
assassinat je rappelle quand même en
passant que à nice un individu sans arme
à feu enfin il a même dit revolver dans
la poche mais c'est pas avec cette arme
qui l'a tué des gens avec un camion il
avait tué quand même 85 ou 86 personnes
le risque est permanent il ne s'agit pas
de réanimer une espèce de paranoïa
il faut quand même avoir à l'esprit que
le risque était courte pour revenir à ce
procès l'audience elle est filmée et
archivés pourquoi c'est nécessaire selon
l'heure c'est nécessaire essentiellement
pour l'histoire pour le futur c'est un
peu comme le procès d'une asie là à lyon
c'est plus pour l'histoire que pour
autre chose
effectivement qu on rappellera dans le
futur qu'il y a eu en france une montée
de l'islamisme avec ses actions
violentes en sachant évidemment que pour
l'instant le problème n'est pas réglé
alors est ce que en tout cas rare il y a
encore des zones d'ombré dans cette
affaire que le procès pourrait éclaircir
ras je pense que tout a été fait dans un
premier temps les auteurs de ces
assassinats ont été abattus maintenant
on travaille sur les conflits sur le
deuxième ou troisième cercle on a
affaire je n'ose pas dire à du menu
fretin parce que ils ont quand même été
une complice d'individus qui ont tué qui
ont massacré
mais pour l'instant je pense que le les
services d' enquêtes ont fait tout le
travail pour identifier ceux qui ont pu
les aider qui ont pu participer à cet
attentat de façon indirecte alors de
nouvelles menaces à ont été diffusés par
al qaïda contre l'équipe de
l'hebdomadaire satirique
rien n'a changé finalement cinq ans
après alors là c'est cette question est
vraiment pour moi une question est
fondamentale fondamentale est importante
au nom de la liberté d'expression
charlie hebdo a ressorti ses dessins
c'est évidemment de une forme de
provocation
maintenant faut-il céder à la menace et
ne pas ressortir ses dessins il est
clair que la lys ont ils ont un peu
appuyé là où ça fait mal
le risque qu'il y ait une réaction
contre des jambes charlie hebdo ou les
responsables existe il est réel
maintenant fallait protéger
cela dit la menace aujourd'hui est quand
même moins forte qu'elle ne l'était il
ya cinq ans car ce qui s'est passé au
moyen-orient notamment là une forme de
stabilité avec l'irak a largement
atténué diminuer le risque d'attentât en
france mais il existe toujours et qu'à
partir de là le mari bull qui peuvent
péter les plombs tout le monde quel type
de menaces justement très concrètement
aujourd'hui
il existe tout simplement que un deux ou
trois individus se regroupent avec des
armes à feu
s'ils en ont des armes blanches et se
livrent à des actions de ce type mais il
est vrai aussi que les services de
renseignement quand même font leur
boulot
le procureur antiterroriste a rappelé il
n'ya pas longtemps qu'une dizaine dans
top d'attentât avait été déjouée en
france qu'il n'a quand même pas empêché
encore une fois qu'il ait eu notamment
pendant la période du confinement deux
ou trois deux actions qui ont entraîné
des morts mais quand même les services
veille la loi la loi sur l'enseignement
de 2015 leur a donné des pouvoirs très
important sans atteindre sans qu'il y
ait atteinte aux libertés individuelles
donc pour l'instant bon ben on est dans
un dans une situation qui est pas trop
angoissante mais il faut rester ville il
faut rester vigilant pour conclure la
phase aps la façon de travailler des
services de renseignement est-ce qu'elle
a beaucoup évolué depuis ces attentats
2015 alors ce qui a surtout évolué c'est
qu'on leur a donné plus de moyens par
cette loi de 2000 qu'un des moyens
juridiques leur permettant de procéder à
plus d' écoutes téléphoniques a plus
parce qu'aujourd'hui la lutte elle et
elle est liée à la technologie donc
possibilité avec les easy cash et on en
a beaucoup parlé des moyens techniques
permettant vraiment d'aller loin dans
les investigations technologiques les
écoule surveillance avec évidemment une
commission de contrôle qui surveille
pour éviter qu'il n'y ait des abus mais
quand même tu ne pars la loi sur
lancement et d'autre part au plan
judiciaire la mobilisation des
magistrats permettant des opérations
judiciaires par anticipation pour les
interpeller des gens et faire des
perquisitions
oui effectivement il ya beaucoup de
moyens juridiques qui ont été engagés et
qui incontestablement permettent aux
services d'être efficace merci beaucoup
rené georges querry d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
l'ancien patron de l'unité de
coordination de la lutte antiterroriste